the president not only one who has a
problem with the press Democrats now
taking a page from the Trump playbook
and going after the media House Minority
Leader Nancy Pelosi blaming the Fourth
Estate for the divide over her
leadership of the Democratic Party and I
know Andy has been on a jag of this this
is one of their priorities to undermine
my prospects the speaker but putting
that aside the I have not asked one
person for a vote I haven't asked a
candidate or an incumbent for a vote and
hours after saying he believes in a Free
Press New York City's Mayor Bill
DeBlasio reportedly had bodyguards
physically remove a credential New York
Post reporter who tried to ask him
questions legitimate questions about his
administration's many meetings with
lobbies de Blasio also taking shots at
Fox News so you'd rather not have the
New York Post or Fox News exists look
it's a free country
I'm saying because they exist we've been
changed for the worst so Jesse you're
gonna stick up for NBC here and say
they're doing right or are you going to
say hey wait wait they went after Trump
too well here's how NBC operates and all
the media does the same thing they'll
find a story they'll seize on it and
they'll try to exploit it for partisan
gain for instance I don't think people
at NBC necessarily like Pelosi so
they're trying to create a little bit of
an anti Pelosi wave and this is how they
do this they will call every single
Democrat in Congress and put them on the
spot in an official capacity and say
listen are you gonna vote for her as
Speaker then they will call every damn
nominee will you vote for her as Speaker
they will call the staff of all the
Democrats in Congress will you vote then
they'll run a poll and then they'll do a
few deep dives and some think pieces and
then they'll maybe book the opponent and
then they'll have a debate on CNN so
they foster this crazy scrum that then
forces the hand of politicians they
could have done this with Dianne
Feinstein you know she had a mole from
China working for her for 20 years they
could have asked every senator on the
Republican and Democratic side do you
condemn this do you feel comfortable
with her they could have asked her
opponent out in California do so they
can foster these types of the momentum
to have people apologize or step down
when they choose a target they're
relentless and they can really this is a
Democrat so Trump says NBC fake news all
right but now they're going after Pelosi
so Kennedy hmm how do I make sense of
this what's going on here well III think
you see the president talking about fake
news and he gets very frustrated that
some of these big outlets like the
failing New York Times are coming after
him and they are quite relentless so I
think what this does is the competing
biases actually negate each other so
this is this is a spot of good news for
the press which has been painted so
partisan and so anti Trump you know the
New York Times if you remember they went
after Hillary in a number of ways and
one of the entities that she blamed for
her failure and her loss what she can
put her own failure likability that
would have been rich no she blamed the
New York Times so it's one of those
things where instead of taking personal
responsibility and doing some thorough
examination of your political life and
the way people perceive you it's much
easier to blame someone else like NBC
which has always always been very left
friendly the funny thing is this is the
one issue where Republicans and far-left
progressives can agree none of them like
Nancy Pelosi and and she is a great
campaign tool for all of them well so
Dana is it a matter of an adversarial
press angering all of our politicians
well look I think also where in the
world would she get the idea that going
after the press works
we learned that okay but it's also NBC
is going where the story is whoever the
leader is they're the one who is going
to get attacked so the two main people
that are being attacked from the right
or the left in this year's midterm
elections with President Trump and Nancy
Pelosi because there is no democrat
equivalent until 2020 of President Trump
so she's going to take all the heat this
was true for Tom Daschle Harry Reid
Mitch McConnell Speaker Boehner this is
normal and it's also where the
controversy is so I think they're
following the story
John fund had a piece of National Review
today I read that as I just coming out
I'm like Jesse's gonna roll the dice but
he said that he thinks that perhaps the
Democrats might have a
first product Ober surprised excuse me
that they will pull Nancy Pelosi from
any consideration for leadership so that
the Democrats have a better chance of
beating Republicans in November don't
know if it's true just passing along
John funds idea so we have a moment of
comedy here tire stories people are
saying well maybe the press is just
doing their job they're going after all
these people at the top well first of
all 20-year mole that's that's pretty
good moly that's what are you know I'm
fine side of most twenty years wow
that's a lot of recordings here's the
thing if you and I always equate things
to my brain always think sports if my GM
is we have a losing season for a decade
it's probably time for the GM to go and
if the fans won't do it because they
love them and Democrats just don't seem
to ever want to make an aggressive move
a lot of yeah unless you're Cleveland
right so the and let's just say that
maybe NBC's a little bit to the left and
they might want to use their platform to
maybe get that horrible GM out so they
start early now maybe one of the players
or will get up and like you know I'll
take that job like this is a great idea
for me I think it's it's more of they're
trying to ignite the base and they're
trying to ignite their party do
something they're just assuming there's
this wave coming but there's no thunder
and lighting or rained to build it up so
I think it's more of like if she don't
we if she won't go on her own rid of our
insurance policy is to make sure she
doesn't run yet got to go and you know
and it's not as though you can't claim
that the Democratic establishment or the
mainstream media is sexist because they
have fallen all over themselves falling
in love with Alexandra Acacio Cortes I
so have we and see so that's where also
we feed the cotton that we go to the
story where's the story she's new she's
the energy Tom Perez the head of the DNC
says she's the future of the roof of the
Democratic Party we're like really okay
we'll check it out and we'll run all the
clips and we'll see it and so I was born
in it we're in the news business you go
to where the story is yeah you know it
strikes me is when the stories came out
about like Ryan's inky or Scott Pruett I
think Pruitt's the one in what try to
get his wife of chick-fil-a for and
other things that that great lotion in
the middle of the night yes but then
they say
fake nose so I don't get it I mean is it
fake or not that NBC lean left
lean right I don't get it I think it
leans left one but not in this case
they're just true they're trying to get
richer good future for the Democratic
Party okay